just 3 hours ago search GPT went live
for 10 million plus chat GPT users then
an hour or so later and ask me anything
on Reddit started with samman and Co
going over much more than just search
gbt oh and earlier today we released the
updated simple bench website and paper
so I will let you decide which of these
is the most enthralling but I'm going to
bring you the highlights of all of them
so buckle up first we have search GPT
which at the moment is just for paid
users of chat GPT but will soon be
coming to everyone apparently and it's
not entirely dissimilar from perplexity
in that you can use llms like chat GPT
to search the web and get links
obviously this is a slight spoiler of
the ask me anything coming in a few
moments but just half an hour ago saman
said of search GPT for many queries he
finds it to be faster and easier to get
the information he's looking for and the
CEO of open AI went further saying
search is my favorite feature that we
have launched in chat PT since the
original launch now many of you may be
thinking that this isn't the first time
that a CEO hyped its product so yes
indeed I did try out search GPT earlier
and there is one thing I concluded
fairly quickly which is that the layout
is very clean I think that's super
intentional given that they're trying to
contrast themselves with the cluttered
layout now of many Google searches as
you guys know you often have to get
through three four even five sponsored
links before you get to the actual
search results and though perplexity Pro
gave me some interesting images on the
right regarding simple bench the answer
was great but I wonder about open AI War
chest what I'm trying to say is that
they don't require advertising Revenue
because they're raking in billions from
subscriptions and we know that within a
few weeks perplexity will be starting to
add ads to their search results or
possibly their follow-up questions but
still ads so what I'm trying to say is
that this clean layout does remind me of
the early Google days and there is
something appealing about that now I
can't of course give you a date for when
free users will get search GPT open AI
say over the coming months so expect it
around 2030 and here's another Edge that
comes with sheer scale and billions of
dollars in funding Partnerships with
news and data providers rather than just
read this out though I thought I would
test it and show you open AI have done a
ton of deals with people like the Ft
Reuters and many others so search GPT
has seamless access to things like the
financial times and just a couple more
quick Impressions before I get to the
Reddit ask me anything with Sam wman on
speed I found search GPT or chat GPT
with search marginally faster actually
than perplexity there was only about a
seconds difference but it was noticeable
I'm sure you guys could come up with
hundreds of examples where perplexity
does better but I do have this recurrent
test if you will for search GPT like
systems I asked for very basic analysis
of upto-date Premier League tables for
the literal ogs of this channel I used
to do something similar for Bing anyway
who is seventh in the Premier League as
of writing that's Noy and Forest and of
course search GPT or chat GPT with
search gets it right or does it if you
look really closely yes noting and
Forest are in seventh but do they have
13 points for sure they won four times
and lost once but didn't they draw as
well no they've got 16 points and I'm
going to be totally honest at this point
I didn't even notice this error until
filming so you've really got to be
careful think of chat gbt with search
less as finding information and more
like generating plausible ideas so the
free perplexity will crush GPC with
search right well not quite they didn't
draw one time they drew four times okay
but perplexity Pro will do better for
sure H well not so much they're saying
tottenham's in seventh for those guys by
the way who don't follow football which
is definitely not soccer there were no
games played today so nothing would have
changed during the search period giving
some credit to chat gbt with search it
did get the follow-up question correct
and notice that this time it correctly
said that Nottingham Forest got 16
points didn't quite notice the
contradiction with the earlier answer
but not too bad just for those of you
who did get early access to search GPT
which we're now calling chat GPT with
search they have improved it according
to them so you might want to check again
if it suits your purposes and they kind
of hint that they used an 01 like
approach to improve or fine-tune GPT 40
to make it better at search get those
good outputs from 01 preview and fine
tune GPT 40 on them clearly something
about perplexity or even search GPT
might have rattled Google because these
AI overviews are everywhere in search
now and I might disappoint some of you
by saying that it's kind of made search
worse you might have got super hyped to
learn that Matthew mcfan is performing
now in the West End yes he is but no he
isn't and I speak from experience with
this anecdote because I was excited told
by someone else that he was in the West
End only to be disappointed when I
looked past the AI results in fact I
tell a lie as soon as I saw it was an AI
overview answer my heart sank so yeah
llms in search is still very much a
Maybe from me now the ask me anything on
Reddit that concluded around an hour or
so ago had more than just Sam opman
quite a few people got involved
obviously quite a few fluff answers but
there were maybe around 10 that I found
quite interesting so obviously I'm just
going to cover for those all of these
guys by the way are Senior Open aai
employees so in no particular order what
is the release date of GPT 5 Sam wman
said we have some very good releases
coming later this year nothing that
we're going to call GPT 5 though when
will you guys give us a new text to
image model Dary 3 is kind of outdated
the next update will be worth the wait
someone said but we don't have a release
plan yet as you'll see in just a second
they are laser focused it seems on
agents you go enjoy your image making
tools we're here to automate the entire
human economy this was perhaps the most
interesting answer is Agi achievable
with known Hardware or will it take
something entirely different we believe
it is achievable with current Hardware
before 01 I'd have probably said total
hype now I'm like H maybe when then will
we get the full 01 release cuz remember
we're using 01 preview currently soon
says Kevin wild their Chief product
officer goes with without saying that
the moment it comes out I'm going to
test it on SIMPLE bench speaking of
simple by the way yes it didn't Escape
my attention the open AI released the
simple QA Benchmark it's totally
different from simple bench as I wrote
All About in my newsletter it's more a
test of factual recall but there were
some genuinely interesting results so do
check out my newsletter the link is in
the description back to the ask me
anything and how does San see AI
augmenting Founders in their Venture
development process basically how will
entrepreneurship change because of AI a
10 times productivity gain is still far
in the future and if that sounds
slightly more cautionary than some of
the mood music I talked about in my
newsletter check out the next answer
this answer came from Mark Chen SVP of
research at openai are hallucinations
the question went going to be a
permanent feature why does 0 preview
when getting to the end of one of its
chains of thought hallucinate more and
more for some context around 18 months
ago and I covered it on this channel on
samman's World Tour he talked about
hallucinations not being a problem in
around 18 months to 2 years well we're
almost at that date and look at the
response to this question again from the
SVP of research at openai Mark Chan
we're putting a lot of focus on
decreasing hallucinations but it's a
fundamentally hard problem the issue as
you might have guessed is that humans
who wrote the underlying text sometimes
confidently declare things that they
aren't sure about a bit like chat gbt
with search then he mentions models
getting better at sighting and training
them better with RL but each of those
feel like sigmoidal methods of
improvement that might taper out as we
get close to 100% or to simplify all of
that I don't think open aai can
currently see a clear path to zero
hallucinations and as I talked about in
my last video until you get reliability
you won't get total economic
transformation as you might expect me to
say as the lead author of simple bench
there are plenty of problems with
current Frontier models spatial
reasoning social intelligence temporal
reasoning but the clear overriding
problem is reliability and what a
wonderful segue I can now do to the next
answer in the ask mean Sam wman was
asked for a bold prediction for next
year 2025 and he said he wants to
saturate all the benchmarks he wants to
crush absolutely every Benchmark out
there so so technically simple bench is
standing in his path 01 preview gets
41.7% my prediction would be that 01
will get around 60% but the human
Baseline non-specialized human Baseline
is
83.7% the top human scorer gets
95.7% I reckon someone should make one
of those metaculus prediction markets
where we can predict whether an open AI
model will get say 90% Plus on simple
bench by the end of next year I'm going
to say no they won't unless perhaps we
find out what did ilas see of course I'm
slightly joking but here's samman's
answer Ilia satova open ai's former
Chief scientist saw the Transcendent
future just to explain the meme by the
way Ilia satsa fired samman before
samman came back and so people
hypothesized that he saw something
dangerous or wild before he fired samman
but mman went on Ilia is an incredible
Visionary and sees the future more
clearly than almost anyone else and is
it me or is there not a slight dis in
this next sentence his early ideas
excitement and vision were critical to
so much of what we have done not his
ideas his early ideas anyway maybe I'm
too cynical but that's what Ilia saw
according to Sam Alman and just a quick
technical one for those waiting for a
video chat with chbt as has been demoed
months ago by open AI they say they're
working on it but don't have an exact
date yet thats to me it's definitely not
going to be this year finally naturally
what is the next breakthrough in the GPT
line of product and what is the expected
timeline yes we're going to have better
and better models saman said but I think
the thing that will feel like the next
giant breakthrough will be agents
everyone working on AI agent startups
just took a big gulp but there we go
straight from samman now if you're one
of those people who think it's all hype
I wouldn't rule them out too early
because now they have the back
of the White House if you want tons more
details on that do check out AI Insiders
on patreon the link is in the
description and I think our Discord just
crossed 1 th000 members so thank you all
and now at long last here is the new
simple bench website of course I
couldn't do it alone so thank you to all
of those who gave their time to help me
and you've got to admit it does look
pretty snazzy we have a short technical
report which I'll touch on in a moment
10 questions to try yourself code and of
course a leaderboard which will stay
updated obviously if I'm in hospital or
something I won't be able to keep it
updated but I will try my best oh and
for those of you who have no idea what
I'm talking about and definitely can't
be bothered to read a technical paper
here's what simple bench is it tests as
you might expect fairly simple
situations for example involving spatial
reasoning what would you say to this
question a juga throws a solid blue ball
a meter in the air and then a solid
purple ball of the same size 2 me is in
the air she then climbs to the top of a
tall ladder carefully successfully
balancing a yellow balloon on her head
at this point by the way where do you
think the balls are well that's the
question where is the purple ball most
likely now in relation to the blue ball
the new Claude sometimes gets this right
but 01 preview not so much and yes don't
worry we thought about prompting how
about telling the models that this might
be a trick question or that they should
factor in distractors and think about
the real world why not throw in a nudge
like it is critical for my career that
you do not get this question wrong well
the results were down here somewhere no
those are the main results where is it
the Special prompt here they are on the
left including the new Claude 3.5 Sonic
yes we do try to stay up to date with
the paper it's only eight pages but it
represents months and months of effort
so do check it out I even give detailed
speculation about why I think models
like gp4 40 underperform I cross
reference other benchmarks like the drop
Benchmark which has really interesting
results of its own relevant to simple
bench and how about this analysis
comparing simple bench results to the
much higher results on some competitor
benchmarks when we created The Benchmark
we didn't know what the results would be
obviously so it could have been that
like maybe 40 mini scores the best and
that would have been interesting I guess
for a video but pretty useless as it
turns out the performance on simple
bench is a pretty good proxy for the
holistic reasoning capability of the
model obviously I am using that word
reasoning quite carefully as I've talked
about in previous videos and I go into
more depth on that in this paper
obviously a ton of limitations to and
avenues for future work all mainly
pertaining to the fact that we didn't
have any organizational backing but I
will bring it back to that Delta between
Frontier Model performance and the human
Baseline and some of these humans had
just High School level education I'm not
saying that a model might not come out
next year that utterly crushes simple
bench I don't think so but it might
happen as I wrote in the conclusion I
think simple bench allows for a broader
view on the capabilities of llms I hope
it in part through this video for
example enhances public understanding of
their weaknesses they don't crush or
saturate every Benchmark just yet they
might be better at quantum physics than
you but not sometimes simple questions
and the question of whether they've
reached human level understanding is
more Nu nuanced than some would have you
believe I'm going to leave it there for
now because I intended this video more
as a taster but the link to simple bench
will be in the description would love to
see you over on patreon but regardless
thank you so much for watching to the
end and have a wonderful day and please
do double check every AI search result